- [Announcer] This UCSD TV program is
presented by University of California
Television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website. Or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape:
bi-pedal, naked large brained. Long the
master of fire, tools and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Richard] I am absolutely thrilled to be
here. But more so I'm thrilled as skin
researcher for the last 20 years and as
chair of the department of dermatology
that this group has decided to focus on
skin and recognize the benefits of this
organ to understand more about who we are
and what ourselves really are made of.
And, of course, the first picture I'd like
to do is to show a couple different hands
that we have in our cover. And these are
the types of hands we like to look at. The
type of skin we like to look at. We have
impressions about ourselves and our health
that's really dictated by the skin. Now,
of course, we recognize ourselves by our
skin. And that's the most obvious function
of all, of what the skin is. There's no
doubt that this is a different species,
perhaps a chimp. And years ago, in the
field of dermatology, there was a very
well-known dermatologist in the name of
William Montagna did quite a bit of
comparative anatomy. Looking at the
histology of different species. And
published a series of fascinating papers
which described many similarities and many
differences between different species in
terms of elements of the skin. And perhaps
what was most interesting about this work
is that this focus of those papers were
really specifically to try to understand
more about ourselves by studying skin
because of primates. Because at that time,
it was easier for him to get primate skin
than it was for him to get human skin. We
also have more rare disorders that, and
somehow, perhaps emphasizes our common
origin, evolutionarily. On the left is an
unfortunate gentleman in China with
something called a large, hairy congenital
nevus. And on the right, is a primate that
has alopecia.
And you wonder if there's some convergence
here, when you look at these types of
photos. And then our government and the
technology-rich world around us exploits
the skin for many things that you may or
may not be aware of. And this is an image
that shows assessing blood flow and
temperature in skin of individuals in an
airport. And it's used actually as a
covert lie detection system to look for
people who might be flushing, nervous. And
it's also used during disease outbreaks
for disease surveillance. This was
particularly prevalent during the SARS
epidemic; trying to pick people who might
have a fever out of a crowd. So the skin
has been exploited by many, many different
ways just from the outside. Sometimes,
looks can be deceiving, and the skin can
fool you. And we take it for granted in
terms of what's going on underneath there.
So I'd like to show you, as skin
biologists, some of the techniques and the
approaches that we use to understand more
about the skin. And to do that, we need to
look more closely what's down deep within
the skin. This is an illustration of what
would happen if you cut a little cube out
of the skin, captured four hair follicles.
The top here is the surface of the skin.
And as we look below the surface, we see
many, many different cell types. In fact,
this is probably the most complex organ
that we have in our body with blood
vessels, nerves, endocrine functions, it
can sweat, it can produce oils, it does
all of this and it must do it in a way
that protects itself from the outside
environment. And as we look more closely,
we see wonderful things going on in these
different cell types within the skin. On
the right, here, is a time-lapse
photography of a live hair follicle
showing how the cells are constantly in
motion, constantly differentiating,
actually regenerating the organ over and
over again. And much of what we've learned
about basic developmental biology, about
stem cells, comes from studying some of
the phenomenal interactions that cells
undergo in this simple little thing of a
hair.
Another way to look at the skin, instead
of cutting through the skin vertically, is
to cut across the top of the surface of
the skin horizontally. And if you did
that, you shave just the top of the skin
and stained what's in there, you see this
network of immune cells. These are called
dendritic cells. And our entire surface of
our skin is covered by this net of cells
that's interacting with the outside
environment. And the classic thoughts
about how those cells interact with the
environment is illustrated in this little
movie. Maybe some of you have seen this.
This actually was a film made in the 1950s
and it was really the dawn of our
understanding of host-immune defense and
how immune cells work. And it shows a
macrophage-like cell, and this little dot
over here, is a bacterium. And it's basic
concept of the time is that we device
specific cells that went out and could
recognize bacteria as bad, as an external
part that we don't want, could chase it
down, as you could see in this movie, the
macrophage is actually changing direction
while it's swimming amongst all these
blood cells and chasing down the bacteria
until it finally can engulf it and kill
it. Well, what we learned about 20 years
ago, now, is that our system that our skin
uses to defend against the outside
environment is more than just specific
cells that are tracking down bacteria. But
that our skin surface also produces
natural antibiotics, we've named these
AMPs, or antimicrobial peptides. And this
is a slide from some work I did when I
was, I guess about 5 years old, because it
was 20 years ago, that shows a brown
staining of the first known mammalian skin
antibiotic.
And this isn't produce by specific immune
cells, but it's actually produced by the
cells that form the surface of the skin,
suggesting that there's more to the way
the skin interacts with the outside
environment that we may otherwise think.
In fact, I want to show you an example of
a wonderful experiment that demonstrates
just how important those surface
antibiotics are to us. And on one side
here, you see a picture of an agar plate
and the way this experiment is done, is
they investigate a very carefully washed
the surface of their hands, touched a
bacteria. And in one case, the bacteria is
Staph.aureus. That's a bacteria that
normally can make infections on the skin.
We know it's dangerous to our skin. And if
you touch those bacteria, wait a few
minutes and then go back later and touch a
plate, you'd see that the bacteria were
able to live on the surface of the skin,
that's why the fingerprints show up, all
those little dots are the bacteria that
lived on the surface of the skin and that
got transferred to the plate. But if you
do the exact same experiment, but now when
you wash your hands instead of touching a
skin bacteria, you touch an intestinal
bacteria like E.coli. This is a pathogen,
too, but it doesn't cause disease in the
skin. You see that when you go back later
and touch your fingers to a plate, all the
E.coli are dead. So this is a great
example and somewhat explains certain
diseases. It explains why Staph.aureus can
be a disease causing organism on skin
because it survives, and why E.coli is
never found as a disease causing organism
in the skin situation, because the skin
makes specific antimicrobials. What's
particularly interesting about this
experiment, though, is the all-important
control. And the scientists love controls.
And that is to do the same experiment that
have sterile surgical gloves on.
So you see what happens, when you have
sterile gloves on and you'd touch
Staph.aureus, and wait a while, and touch
your glove-covered bacteria on the plate,
some of the Staph.aureus survived but
they're not as, they're not doing so well.
They actually missed the fact that they
were on the surface of our skin. But look
at what happened with the E. Coli. These
gloves touched the same number of E.coli
as the bare fingertips did. And you can
see the E.coli survive very, very well
when the gloves are on your hand. So, what
does that mean practically for our
everyday life, thinking about the skin?
Well, it means that gloves protect
bacteria from us. Particularly, bacteria
that cause intestinal diseases. And you
should think about that when you go
through the cafeteria line. So, that's my
segue into some of our research that I
like to talk about, I hope you'll agree
with me, or at least think about the fact
that perhaps how we think about ourselves
as humans shouldn't just be this
antagonistic relationship between us
defending against them. But as you'll hear
later in the afternoon, there's quite a
bit of information that's coming from the
field of microbiome research that says
that these bacteria that are on us,
perhaps they're not all so bad. And is it
possible that a lot of the skin bacteria
that normally survive on us are not just
bystanders? And what I want to lead to is
to ask you to think about the question,
“Should we really completely rethink
established approaches to the study of
human origin based on these observations
made in the skin?” Classically, we think
about this type of tree of life in
evolution where single-cell organisms
evolved into complex organisms like
humans.
But I propose to you, that perhaps we
should flip this on it's head and think
about it, really, that we have evolved to
serve the master microbes. And we're all
these little different types of organisms,
some dropped off the evolutionary tree,
and some survive. But we're here, in part,
to serve the microbe and perpetuate it's
survival. And I think you would agree that
with the expansion of humans, the
expansion of the microbes that we carry is
going to be just as successful, so it's
good for them, too. So what's the evidence
to support this kind of crazy thinking?
Well, has human skin and microbe really
co-evolved to serve each other? Are the
microbes one of our own cells, not just
something foreign, but is this part of us?
And there's lots of evidence now to
really, I think, very clearly show us that
specific types of bacteria, specific
microbes on the skin are absolutely
essential to human health. How could this
be? Well, one way we understood this is
when we realize that the microbes aren't
just living outside on the surface.
They're not outside the door but they're
really integral in that little piece of
skin that I illustrated to you earlier.
This is some work done by a couple of
scientists in my lab over the last few
years showing how microbes are not just at
the surface, and that's these little tiny
purple dots, and the epidermis is the top
layer of the skin. And if you look down in
the hair follicle, you see lots of
microbes, that wasn't such a surprise. But
what was a surprise to us and many others
is that if you look in areas that we
thought were sterile, even in healthy skin
that hasn't been injured, that's normally
working, there's collections of microbes
that live down amongst our inner fat, in
the tissues between our blood vessels. And
they're there in a place where they could
be interacting with the rest of our body.
One of the ways that microbes benefit us
on our skin can be illustrated by an
experiment just like the one I showed you
before, but with a little bit of a twist.
So, this is an experiment, again those
three lines are fingertips. And now the
investigator was a graduate student in my
lab, Anna Cogen, who washed her hands very
carefully of the normal bacteria and
touched a type of bacteria known as Group
A Streptococcus. This is also known as the
flesh-eating bacteria. So normal ones
would be very dangerous. This was a type
of bacteria that we attenuated so it's
relatively safe. Well, why we used these
bacteria is that they are a pathogen, so
they're a foreign bacteria, we don't want
them. And secondly, that they have a
unique capacity to lyse red blood cells.
So, you can see them really obviously when
you touch a plate that has blood in it. It
lyses it, that's why it's all clear. So
what happens if she has on her fingertips
not the bad guys, the flesh-eating
bacteria, but these are normal fingertips
colonized with a type of bacteria that you
all have on your skin right now at a
concentration of somewhere between 10,000
and 100,000 per square centimeter. You
have a lot of these bacteria, known as
Staph.epidermidis, epidermis for the skin.
So these are not disease, this isn't
dirty, this was normal. And if you touch
this plate with skin that's populated with
those, you can see those bacteria because
they make these little tiny dots here,
shadows. So now, here's the question. What
happens if Anna, instead of washing her
hands really carefully before touching the
flesh-eating bacteria, just had let the
normal bacteria survive on her skin, the
healthy type of bacteria? Well, this is
what happens. She touched the same amount
of bacteria, it's on the far right here.
But now, in this case with your healthy
bacteria there, it's fighting, it's
helping you resist the flesh-eating
bacteria. And she'd gone on to actually
identify new antibiotics from these types
of bacteria.
And there are many hundreds of new
antibiotics that can be discovered just
within our own ecosystem, on our surface
of the skin. Another way that bacteria
control us, is they influence how much of
a rash, or how much inflammation you can
have. And this is a very dramatic
experiment, again, using this model of the
skin cartoon that shows if you cut your
skin or scratch your skin, and it's
absolutely sterile and you have no
bacteria on it, the amount of swelling and
redness and scaliness is much, much
greater than if the skin has a normal
microbiome. And you can see that here in
this microscopic image how thick a sterile
wound it as opposed to non-infected but a
normal skin wound with a normal microbial
community. So the microbes are defending
us against flesh-eating bacteria, some
microbes are controlling our immune
system. And this is some very recent work
that we've done to look at a very common
type of disease known as atopic
dermatitis. Here's a picture of a child in
the corner here on the bottom with a
complication of this disease. It's a type
of eczema and these patients
unfortunately, very often get
Staph.infections, that was that bacteria
that we showed you in the glove
experiment. And when you look at normal
population, this is several thousand
samples, most of the normal bacteria on
healthy individuals produce these
antibiotics that kill Staphylococcus
disease causing bacteria. But in patients
with eczema, there's very few, actually,
of the normal type of bacteria. They're
displaced by another bacteria. It's
neither disease causing, nor normal. It's
kind of inert. It doesn't do us any good.
And when that happens, these individuals
then start to get Staph.infections.
There's a very, very strict correlation
between the capacity to get a
Staph.infection and whether or not you
have these bacteria.
So, what can you do with this type of
realization? Well, you can try to help
people, which is ultimately why we do our
research. And this is showing an
experiment, this is beginning of a large
clinical trial, we're doing a number of
cities. This is now eight patients, but
kind of show you what happens. This is the
average result. And on the blue side is
before treatment. And then amount of
Staph.aureus. And the red side is after
you put a treatment on. So, first is the
control, you just put a moisturizing cream
on. And you see the amount of the infected
bacteria, if anything it goes up a little
bit, doesn't really change. And what if
you put one of these inert bacteria like
are found in patients with the disease?
Oh, nothing happens. If you put a cream
that has those bacteria on it, the
patients stay the same, they still have
less, a lot of Staph.aureus. But now
here's strain two. This is a bacterial
strain from a normal person, that's
transplanted onto the disease skin. And
you can see this bacterial strain just in
a single application causes over 100 fold
decrease in the amount of infectious
bacteria. This has worked actually to
every single patient we tried so far. So
we better stop the study now, right?
Before we find out it doesn't work. But
we're very excited about it. And I think
it's further showing how some microbes,
not all microbes, are our friends. And
some microbes are clearly our enemies. So,
how should be think about this in this
conference? Well, I'd like to propose to
you the concept of the super organism. We
probably only inherit, of our total
genetic makeup in our bodies, probably
only about 10% of it really comes from our
parents, because 90% of the organisms that
we carry around from us are microbes. So
that means, when you think about it, most
of the genetic material we're carrying
around, we can exchange. We're not stuck
with the things our parents gave us. We
can exchange bacteria just by shaking
hands. And if anybody is really healthy
here, I'd like to shake hands with you.
And what it really also means of course,
we realize this already, but our
environment can directly influence who we
are. And this now starts to get us to a
molecular and genetic explanation for
something we've observed for a very long
time. Certain environmental situations
affect health and that might be because
those environmental situations are
affecting the health of the cells on us
that are microbes. So with that, I'd like
to suggest that understanding the pro- and
anti-microbial systems of primates and
humans can better define who we are. And
thank you very much for your time.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Michael] Today's talk, what I'm going
to discuss really, are properties of human
skin that support thermoregulation. Humans
have an exceptional capability to protect
against rises in body temperature, or
minimize heat storage when performing
physical work in hot environments. This
great thermoregulatory capacity probably
provides several selective advantages.
One, and these have been pointed out by
Dr. Dan Lieberman, that in early hominins
that the ability to forage safely during
peak heat times allow them to gather food
where the hunters that would use the
humans as prey, basically had to sit and
use behavioral thermoregulation because
they couldn't do muscular work in the heat
of the day. Another potential selective
advantage is that some humans may have
participated in persistence hunting. This
required them to perform at a fairly
substantial metabolic rate for extended
durations to move animals probably of
larger size and maybe herbivores for
extended periods of time until these
animals suffered high body temperatures
and succumbed from heat stroke and thus,
then became food for the hunters.
So the question really arises then, why
can humans thermoregulate in hot
conditions while foraging and hunting? Now
remember, we're talking two things, the
skin for thermoregulation, but also
somehow the skin not only dumping the
heat, but also maybe participating in the
ability to sustain exercise. So humans can
do this because they have, really from a
thermoregulatory point of view, two unique
features. The first is the ability to
regulate a steady state core temperature
during physical exertion. That's pretty
much dependent on the metabolic rate and
reasonably independent of the environment.
We won't talk much about that today. But
that's very much made possible by the
skin's capacity to support a very high
heat loss. Now, what I've done here is
I've constructed a table that I'm going to
address in the subsequent slides, "Factors
that support high skin heat loss." If you
look on the left here, where we have the
different factors, you'll notice that four
of these obviously relate to heat
exchange, upright posture, which I'll
explain, skin blood flow, sweating and
large surface area. Now, these provide
certain advantages but on the other hand,
as I'm going to show you a little later,
they provide also problems for the body
particularly cardiovascular nature. And
there's properties of the skin or organs
within the skin that help offset these
disadvantages, such as sodium
reabsorption, and several different
reflexes which I'll talk. So, the skin can
provide large heat exchange but it also
can present problems when trying to
perform sustained work in the heat. Let's
talk first about upright posture. The
advantages of an upright posture are
fairly obvious. First of all, you have a
smaller surface area exposed for solar
radiation.
As a result to that, you don't absorb the
solar radiation as much. So you have less
of environmental heat stress. Second, and
not as obvious, if you're upright and your
skin's exposed and I'm locomoting and
moving forward, I'm going to have more air
movement across my skin than if I was
haunched over. And as a result of that, I
improve both the convective and
evaporative heat capacitie, or the
abilities for heat loss. And third,
bipedal locomotion also results in lower
efficiency, so lower metabolic rate and
rate of heat production to be dissipated.
Now before I go on, I'm just going to give
some very basics of heat balance. When an
individual performs physical exercise, the
amount of heat they produce is
proportionally to how hard they exercise,
because when muscles contract, only
roughly 20% of that energy goes into
contractal shortening. The remaining 80%
is heat that needs to be dissipated by the
body. Now, I showed the brain here because
as the body stores heat, unfortunately
there's a lot of myths that humans have
selective brain cooling. They don't. That
the brain is pretty much either similar to
arterial blood pressure or arterial blood
temperature, our recent evidence shows it
might be slightly higher, is that as body
temperature increases, we really rely on
the skin for heat loss. So that the
central nervous system acting through the
sympathetic nervous system has a
proportionate physiological
thermoregulatory system that, A, increases
skin blood flow that allows radiative and
convective heat loss, and two, increases
sweating which allows, if adequate
biophysics, evaporation. Let's first
discuss active vasodilation. Humans,
compared to most species, have very highly
vascularized skin. And for you sitting in
a room at a room temperature maybe 20 some
degrees, 22 degrees, you probably have
your subcutaneous vessels constricted.
So normally, if we look over here, we have
constricted cutaneous vessels. Now, when
an individual goes into the heat, two
things occur. First of all, the skin
becomes warm, and that takes away the
constrictor effect. And second, which is
very unique to humans, at least to my
knowledge, is that you have active
cutaneous vasodilation. That sympathetic
innervation through a variety of different
pathways, cause active vasodilation of the
skin in proportion to the heat load of the
body. So, the greater the heat load, the
greater the vasodilation. And thus, then
is this warm blood moves to the surface of
the skin, if the temperature gradient is
from the skin to the ambient conditions,
we now can have convective and radiative
heat loss. So, in this figure cartoon, we
show the impact of skin blood flow and
this is whole body skin blood flow as a
function of core temperature. What you can
see is this, if an individual is resting,
you can achieve very high skin blood
flows, up to eight liters a minute, which
is extremely high because we know in a
temperate environment, cardiac output is
only about five liters per minute sitting,
average human. With exercise, we find
again that at a given threshold, that the
skin temperature will increase but it
cannot increase as high as it can when
you're sitting at rest. And this is
because of this blood pressure problem
that you have constrictor tones so that
you don't have as high as a vasodilation.
But you probably can have skin blood flows
maybe in the range of five to six liters.
Now, the second avenue of heat loss is
through eccrine sweating, eccrine sweat
glands. Eccrine sweat glands, at least in
their number and dispersion, are fairly
unique to humans. We have about one and a
half to four million. They're located over
the entire skin. They're sympathetically
cholinergic innervated.
They secrete a very hypotonic fluid to the
surface of the skin. Obviously, as this
fluid evaporates, it then results in
cooling of the superficial areas of the
skin and also the blood within the
capillaries. So, eccrine sweat glands are
different from the apocrine glands which
are often located with hair and again,
they're located over the entire body. Now,
humans can have very high levels of sweat
rate. And as a result, if that sweats
evaporate, they can have tremendous
amounts of evaporative cooling. And this
is why they can live in environments where
the ambient temperature is higher than
their skin temperature. Here we have some
data cartoon of a plot of whole body sweat
rate as a function of exercise intensity.
As we move this way, people are running
harder, and it's going from a cool to a
hot condition. The first point I want to
make is this, we've all seen crazy numbers
in the literature about how much people
can sweat. Generally it's not unusual if
you're doing sustained hard work in the
heat to have a sweat rate of one liter per
hour, maybe a liter and a half. The
highest sweat rates that I've seen doing
thousands of experimental bodies, about a
little over two liters. People do report
in literature two and a half to three and
half liters per hour. I haven't seen them.
I assume it's possible and it's very
extreme athlete for short period of time.
But high sweat rates can be sustained in
the areas of a liter and a half. Now, when
you have these high rates of water flux,
you have to remember that the sweat comes
from the interstitial fluid which comes
from the plasma. So as you sweat, you're
going to decrease water in your plasma in
your interstitial space and your
extracellular fluid volume. So as a
result, if you're sweating and you're not
replacing fluids, your blood volume with
decrease as you dehydrate. So now, what we
see is that as an individual is exercising
in the heat for whatever purpose, of
foraging or hunting, that we have this
great capacity for heat loss, but we have
two penalties, and this is shown in a
cartoon.
The first is that if we look, what we have
here, is the blood distribution in a
person standing like myself in a cool
environment. You can see that the blood's
pretty much distributed in the thoracic
area, it's easier to return blood volume
to the heart so that you can sustain
cardiac output, or how much blood flow
goes per unit time. Now, with heat stress,
you have two things that occur first. One
is you have the increase skin blood flow.
But what I also didn't mention, if the
superficial veins become warm, they become
compliant, so the blood sits in the
periphery. This means that the blood is
not in the thoracic area, it's more
difficulty to return to the heart, reduces
filling and makes it more difficult to
sustain cardiac output while
simultaneously performing exercise. So
one, the displacement. Two, that second
problem is that as I had told you, that if
you decrease your total body water and
dehydrate, the liquid portion of your
blood decreases so your plasma volume,
your blood volume reduces. All at the same
time, is when I'm standing upright, so I
have to work against gravity to perfuse
the brain, and I'm exercising and have to
perfuse skeletal muscles. So this really
causes a conundrum in terms of the human
body. Well, the skin helps to address
this. And I'm going to give several ways
that it does this. First of all, not only
do eccrine sweat glands secrete hypotonic
fluid, but they have the ability to
reabsorb sodium. That, basically you have
a reabsorption duct. So that as the sweat
comes down, that humans can reabsorb
sodium. And how much sodium they can
reabsorb depends on how well they're
acclimatized to the heat. Here's some data
that shows local sweat rate over an area
of skin, and the sodium concentration in
the secreted sweat in one, people that are
unacclimatized to the heat, people that
live in Boston in the winter time.
And people that are acclimatized in the
heat, people that live in Atlanta, where I
live currently, in the summer time. And
what you can see that obviously the higher
the sweat rate, the less efficient the
active transport is because the sodium is
moving by and you can only retake up so
much. But with acclimatization, you can
greatly reduced the amount of sodium in
the sweat. And in fact, you can basically
have as third as much...a third less
sodium in the sweat after acclimatization.
So it may not be unusual at all to see
sodium in secreted sweat on acclimatized
person, maybe 50, 60 mili-equivalents and
10 maybe, not 10, but 20 mili-equivalents.
Well, this is important because this
sodium that's reabsorbed goes back into
the interstitial, into the plasma and into
the extracellular space. And when we look
at the extracellular fluid space, the
volume in that space is very much
dependent on sodium concentration. That's
the primary cation that's the difference
between the intracellular space. So as we
absorb sodium back into our plasma, our
extracellular sodium concentration
increases and this results in an osmotic
gradient that causes you to pull water
from inactive muscle, where water is
plentiful. So this retention of sodium
then, allows the inactive muscle to pull,
act as a reservoir. So this is a way that
you can defend your blood volume or your
plasma volume by moving water throughout
the body. So, it's very important because
at a given level of dehydration, plasma
volume would be reduced less. Now, what is
also not as obvious in, as being much more
well understood lately is that skin
provide sensory information that supports
thermoregulation. And just simplistically,
I'm going to call these cold receptors,
warm receptors, and mechanical receptors.
But through these receptors, we can sense
wetness, and we also can sense
thermocomfort, or thermal sensations.
The wetness sensation, I'm going to show
you in a minute, is very important because
as the skin is wet, that means that skin
is not evaporating that helps you
basically reduce your sweating rate so you
have less wasteful sweating to defend your
body water. And thermal sensations are
extremely important, is that A, they drive
behavioral thermoregulation, skin
temperature, skin wetness, as well as
heart rate are what drive that. And in
addition, I'm going to show you a reflex
that's probably related to the skin that's
not often appreciated that can actually
drive the core temperature to help reduce
skin blood flow requirements. Let's first
move and look at the impact of wet skin on
sweat suppression. Here we have on the
Y-axis, total body sweating rate during
minutes of exercise where individuals are
performing a given metabolic rate of
exercise over a 30 minute duration. One
time, they are not acclimatized to the
heat and the other time, they're
acclimatized. During this period of time,
the investigators are continually ramping
up humidity. So, here in the beginning,
it's dry, and here at the end, it's very
humid, it keeps getting more and more
humid. First thing is that, you can note
that if humans acclimatize to the heat,
they can have a much higher sweating rate.
So you see a much higher sweating rate in
acclimatized individuals. But second, and
very important is that you can see that as
the humidity increases, the sweating rate
decreases, whether they're unacclimatized
or not. So the body is sensing that the
skin is wet, that the sweat is not being
evaporated, it's being wasted, and as a
result, I'll tune down my wetedness. And
this really can have a lot of important
implications. Here are some old studies
that were done, where they got a large
number of people and they had them perform
the same amount of physical activity,
outdoors, in a desert and a tropic
environment. So, they had the same
metabolic rates, so they had roughly the
same amounts of heat to be dissipated.
But on one condition, the tropics, the
skin is wet, and then the other condition,
the desert, the skin is dry. What you can
see that for 24 hours, sweat rates for
this population, it greatly reduced the
water requirement from about maybe five
liters down to two or three, so half the
water requirements. So, by reabsorbing
sodium, I can move water into, from
reservoirs within my body to defend blood
volume, by having skin wetedness, I can
sense that and I can reduce how much I
lose and how much I dehydrate. So, skin is
very important, then, for allowing
individuals to minimize the effects of
dehydration. Now, I don't have a good
slide to show this. If I did, I would take
my 10 minutes to explain it, but when
humans basically perform exercise under
most environmental conditions, how high
their core temperature lies is a function
of metabolic rate. And it's pretty much
independent of the environment. But what
you see, as the environment gets warmer,
and the skin gets warmer, there is a point
where the steady state core temperature
will elevate. So, the core temperature
will elevate, but there is still
sufficient biophysics that you can just
maintain that. So for some reason, and
it's been known for a long time, that
humans then will somehow pick to have a
higher core temperature at times. And this
really kind of befuddled physiologists
because back in the old days, they used to
think high core temperature's bad, low
core temperature's good, sort of like
Animal Farm, "Four legs good, two legs
bad." So what Dr. Rall, Larry Rall from
University of Washington pointed out very
elegantly is that this actually provides
an advantage. And here I'm going to show
you a table. Here we have an individual
exercising in the heat, three different
times, same metabolic rate, same amount of
evaporative heat loss. But here we have
now a core temperature of 38, skin
temperature of 34.
So we have a core-to-skin temperature
gradient of four degrees. What we see,
then, is if we do the calculations, you
would require a skin blood flow of about
two and a half liters. Now, if it got
warmer outside, and the skin temperature
went up, you have a smaller gradient and
now it requires more, because you have a
smaller gradient now from the skin to the
ambient, so you have to move more blood
through the skin to have the same amount
of heat loss to defend core temperature.
So what happens is when core temperature
actually rises up, it widens the
core-to-skin temperature gradient, and it
reduces the skin blood flow requirement
thus relieving some of the cardiovascular
stress. So in summary, I think that when
we look at the skin and how it supports
thermoregulation, we not only have to
think about heat loss, but we have to
think about the other functions that it
does that supports the cardiovascular
system. I think we've established that
skin has an exceptional heat loss
capability. That you probably can have
maximum skin blood flows up to eight
liters. That would be for a seated person
in the heat, but very substantial. That
you can have a very high sweating rates at
least in maybe the unique Olympic athlete
up to three liters per hour, but are
probably generally must be lower in other
individuals. And that skin supports blood
pressure regulation, one, through sodium
conservation, which pulls water from the
intracellular spaces particularly in
active muscle, to help support blood
volume. Two, by suppressing the weted skin
so that we don't have wasteful sweat. All
of these acting against dehydration. And
then through thermal sensations, by one,
working to allow behavioral
thermoregulation so that the individual
could titrate the work load, or seek shade
so they don't work too hard. But also
probably combined with information from
baroreceptors within the cardiovascular
system to allow the thermoregulatory
system to allow core temperature to drift
up and reduce cardiovascular strain. Thank
you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Sarah] So as we all know, mammalian
skin is decorated with diverse appendages
including our mammary glands, and hair
follicles with our associated sebaceous
glands, and apocrine glands which are
found in hair follicles mainly in the
axillary regions in humans. And also,
eccrine sweat glands which play an
extremely important regulation in human
thermoregulation. So the questions I'd
like to address in this talk are: Firstly,
“How did these organs evolve?” And
secondly, “Do they have a common
evolutionary origin?” For the most part,
skin has not left us with a fossil record.
And so, this makes it very difficult to
answer these types of evolutionary
questions. But one approach to addressing
these issues, is to ask whether the
development and genetics of these organs
can give us some clues to their evolution.
So during embryonic development, it turns
out that the very early stages in the
formation of mammary glands, hair
follicles, and sweat glands, are
morphologically very similar. So the
mammary gland develops from the ectoderm.
This is the outermost layer of the embryo
and it's diagrammed here in pink, and
underlying mesenchymal cells which is
shown as black dots. And the first sign of
glandular development is a localized
thickening in the ectoderm, which is
called a placode and this then buds down
into the mesenchyme and induces the
formation of a fat pad. After that, the
mammary sprout continues to grow downwards
and starts to branch and develops a lumen.
If we look at hair follicle development,
we find that this is also characterized
firstly by the formation of a localized
thickening in the ectoderm followed by
formation of a bud. And after that stage,
the development of hair follicles diverges
from the that of mammary glands. The last
organ to develop in embryonic life out of
these three is the eccrine sweat glands
which form around birth. And these also
form first through thickening of the
surface ectoderm, budding into the
mesenchyme and then further down growth,
which in this case involves curling of a
tube to form the gland and the development
of the lumen. Another thing that these
organs all have in common is that we know
that it's extremely important that the
cells of different types are able to
communicate with each other. So in each
case, the epithelial and mesenchymal cells
engage in extensive cross talk between
these different cell types. So this cross
talk is made possible by the secretion of
signaling factors from one cell that is
then received by another cell and cause
changes in this receiving cell that can
include changing its proliferation status
or its fate. Two of the really important
cell-cell signaling pathways that are
involved in early stages of appendage
development are the Wnt signaling pathway,
and the ectodysplasin or EDA signaling
pathway. In each case, these involves
secreted Wnt ligans, secreted ligans that
are received by a receptor. In the Wnt
pathway, the ligan is known as Wnt. So
this is made by another cell and it floats
out and then starts to interact with
receptors on the receiving cell.
And this causes a whole series of
intracellular changes that end up with the
activation of target gene expression and
these genes then can cause a change in
fate of the cell. Ectodysplasin signaling,
similarly involves a secreted ligan, in
this case called EDA, and this interacts
with its receptor and causes a different
set of changes intracellularly. But these
also result in expression of target genes.
So it turns out, that Wnt signaling is
absolutely key for the formation of all of
these different appendages, if its absent,
they completely fail to form. And if you
over activate this pathway using genetic
tricks in mice, we see that you get extra
appendages forming. Downstream of Wnt
signaling, the ectodysplasin pathway is
activated. And this requires Wnt in order
to get started, but then takes over from
Wnt in further promoting the formation of
these organs. So both the similar
morphology and the similar molecular
pathways involved in the formation of
these diverse organs suggest that they may
have a common origin. If we look during
evolution, our ancient ancestors, the
sauropods, had, at least some of them,
were thought to have a glandular skin. And
this was selected for in the therapsids.
And these animals lacked scales, in fact,
and had completely glandular skin. And
people have argued that one of the
functions of this glandular skin was to
provide moisture through skin secretions
to the eggs of these creatures, which are
known to have been very thin-walled and
would likely have dehydrated otherwise.
The development of hair has been argued to
be possibly a specialization that could
have led to...that could have aided in the
delivery of glandular secretions to eggs.
So the mammals that exist today, fall into
several classes of which the Monotremes
still lay eggs and they lack nipples and
suckle their young via specialized hairs.
And these animals include the Spiny
Anteaters and Platypus. Whereas marsupials
do have nipples, but these "nipple
primordia" actually co-form hair follicles
and mammary glands during development as
I'll show you in a minute. The placental
animals which include ourselves have
developed hairless nipples. And these
probably facilitate the suckling of
newborns. So there is also some molecular
evidence for this kind of a scheme. So, it
was thought that the mucus secreting
surface epithelia make anti-microbial
enzymes as an important function of these
epithelia, and these include xanthine
oxidoreductase and lysozyme. And as glands
developed in order to more effectively
secrete these antimicrobials and
eventually forming mammary glands. At the
same time as this development or evolution
occurred, the gene in coding lysozyme
actually became duplicated. And one of the
copies evolved into the alpha lactalbumin
gene and this encodes an important
component of milk and is also involved in
the manufacture of lactose, another
important component of milk.
It's also been shown that xanthine
oxidoreductase has a secondary function in
addition to its antimicrobial properties.
It's also important in encasing fat
droplets in milk and allowing their
secretion. So, these enzymes seem to have
adopted additional functions that allow
them to help in milk production. Another
piece of evidence that...for a common
origin for mammary glands and hair
follicles came, as I already mentioned,
from studies of marsupial mammary
development. So in marsupials, the nipple
develops, as I mentioned already, from a
thickening in the ectoderm. And this
elongates and develops two types of
sprouts, a primary sprout and secondary
buds. And these secondary buds go on to
form mammary glands whereas the primary
sprouts develop into hair follicles with
associated sebaceous glands. So this is
all happening during the embryonic
development of the marsupial. And the last
stage of development, the nipple actually
everts and it retains these sebaceous
glands and of course the mammary glands,
but the hair follicles degenerate in most
marsupials. Although it is known that
koala bears actually have hair still
emanating from their nipples. So, this
common development of these different
types of organs in the same structure
really provides support for the idea that
these things may have co-evolved. So of
course, the numbers and locations of
mammary glands have evolved to fit the
litter size and feeding position.
So in humans, we generally have one baby
and we have two mammary glands. The babies
are usually, we usually hold our babies to
our chest and that's where the mammary
glands are located. By contrast, pigs have
very large litters with an average size of
10 and they have 12 to 14 nipples or tits.
They tend to feed in a lying position and
their nipples are located all along the
side of their body. Cattle, generally have
a litter size of one and only four nipples
or tits. And they feed standing up with
the mammary tits in an inguinal position.
So, what are the mechanisms that may have
permitted these adaptation of mammary
gland numbers and locations to fit the
needs of these species? So in many
mammals, the embryonic mammary glands
actually form along a line between the
fore- and hindlimb buds in the embryo and
this is known as the milk line or mammary
line. And it gradually becomes fragmented
resulting in the formation of mammary
buds. And this is diagrammed for a mouse
embryo. We can see something very similar
in the rabbit embryo. And this is a
scanning electron microscopy that allows
us to actually visualize this raised
mammary ridge. And this can also be seen
in human embryos. So as I mentioned, the
Wnt signaling pathway plays key roles in
the initiation of mammary gland
development. So there's no mammary
development without this signal. And if we
over activate it, you can get extra
mammary glands. And we can visualize this
nicely by looking at one of the Wnt ligans
called Wnt10b, and here we're using a
technique called [inaudible 00:52:04] to
look at where the Wnt10b mRNA is being
made and this appears as a reddish brown
stain.
So we can see the stains all along the
milk line and is elevated in the
developing mammary buds. And
interestingly, in mice which lack a
secreted inhibitor protein, which would be
expected to result in excess Wnt
signaling, we find that these developed
extra nipples and extra mammary glands. So
these findings suggest that changes in the
pattern of Wnt signaling activity could
underlie the adaption of mammary gland
location and number. So, like the mammary
gland, our hair and sweat gland formation
varies greatly between mammalian species,
but also, varies within species. So if we
think about humans, of course we have nice
long hair on our head and very short, fine
hairs over the rest of our body. But
within our species, that hair can vary
greatly in its texture and its thickness.
Our apocrine glands, as I mentioned, are
mostly axial and we have eccrine sweat
glands all over our body. By contrast, a
polar bear has hair that's of rather
similar length over most of its body, but
this hair is specially adapted and it has
a large air pockets that allow much better
thermoregulation for the polar bear in
cold conditions. It also, interestingly,
has apocrine glands on the soles of its
feet and leaves a scent trail with these.
And its eccrine glands are confined to the
soles of the feet unlike in humans.
Horses apparently completely lack eccrine
glands and instead they sweat by a
different mechanism that utilizes apocrine
glands which are located all over the body
of the horse. And when these are active
you get this lathering appearance that we
see for instance in race horses. And the
hair of the body is mostly...the hair of
the horse is mostly short but has
specialize appearances on their tail and
the mane where it's very long. So there's
an incredible amount of variation here.
For both hair follicles and eccrine sweat
glands, the ectodysplasin signaling
pathway plays various key roles at early
stages of development. And indeed, loss of
function of this pathway in humans leads
to syndromes where there is really an
absence of all these organs. More relevant
to evolution, though, it turns out that
there's a variant of the receptor for
ectodysplasin which is associated with
increased activity of this receptor. And
in Asian populations, this variant
receptor is specifically seen in people
who have thick, straight hair, and
increased numbers of eccrine sweat glands.
Particularly in the Lee and Han
populations, this variant is extremely
predominant. And this is illustrated here
using a...looking at Asian populations and
individuals who have either straight or
non-straight hair. And you can see that if
you have the 370A variant of EDAR, you're
much more likely to have straight hair.
Whereas individuals with non-straight
hair, have more or less equal chance of
having either that A or the V variant.
And we can model this in mice by
genetically replacing the V variant of the
gene with an A variant and this in mice,
as well as in humans, results in the
formation of thicker hair, and also an
increased number of sweat glands. So, here
we're looking at the foot pad of a mouse,
actually several mice, and these are
stained with blue stain to reveal the
glands. And you can see the greatly
increased numbers of these glands in the A
variant. So mutation of EDAR to a more
active form may underlie a subset of human
variation in hair thickness and
straightness, and sweat gland density. So
just to summarize what I've told you,
evidence from development, genetics and
evolutionary studies suggest that mammary
glands, sweat glands and hair follicles
may be derived from a common precursor.
The function of this precursor may have
been to hydrate and protect thin-walled
eggs and later developed nutritional
functions as well. Mammary gland evolution
preceded the birth of live young. And
mammary gland adaptation may have occurred
in part through altered control of Wnt
signaling. Whereas variation in hair
thickness and sweat gland density are
associated with altered ectodysplasin
signaling. Now, there's an awful lot that
we don't know. Some very straightforward
questions such as, “What controls the
formation of different types of appendages
in specific regions of the body?” “How and
why did human eccrine glands becomes
ubiquitous to over our body and
intermingled with hair follicles?” And
very straightforward questions like, “Why
is human scalp hair longer than body
hair?” And of interest to many men in the
audience, “Why do many human males lose
their hair in a particular pattern?”
And I'm sure you can think of many
additional questions that we really don't
know the answers to yet and would like to.
So just to reiterate, that in future
studies, because of the relative dearth of
fossil records for mammalian skin, these
types of developmental and molecular
approaches to skin evolution can be
particularly useful. And this is just my
lab who contributed to some of the work
that I showed you. And thank you for your
attention.
♪ [music] ♪